so this will be a benchmark day we'll
look back on that fondly
[Music]
Chuck what's been bugging you lately
I'll tell you I don't know if it's
bugging me maybe I'm happy about it
maybe maybe the entire human race has
something to be hopeful about and you
know how I feel about climate and the
climate crisis right
so they they I wake up this morning and
it's all about fusion fusion everywhere
everybody's talking about fusion fusion
fusion I'm like whoa whoa is this a good
thing or are they yanking my chain are
they just making me what are they doing
are they are they doing the Lucy pull
the football away from me
what is happening what is happening with
the fusion oh okay so
uh the Highlight is at one of the
National Laboratories uh Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratories
where they they among all the National
Labs are one of their major tasks is as
Shepherds of our nuclear Arsenal
okay the nuclear fuel basically so
radioactive materials that might be used
in weapons and it is funded by the
department of energy not the Department
of Defense
so that in fact the total amount of
money we spend on defense is not only
the dod's budget but an important
fraction of the Department of Energy's
budget that involves uh Weaponry
basically okay right yes so there they
have the world's most powerful laser and
what they do with a bunch of these
lasers is they aim them all at a tiny
Target and they cause the target to
explode all right okay
sounds like America so far
so if the target is uniformly heated you
know evenly in all directions and the
material is very uniform in all
directions so that would be a spherical
shape then the explosion creates an
implosion on the other side of that
explosion right you can't just have
stuff come out unless the Newton's law
for every action is an equal and
opposite reaction so reaction explosion
that comes out creates an explosion that
points inward
okay very high pressure and very high
temperature and under those conditions
you can take two atoms light atoms right
and merge them into a heavier atom sweet
that takes a lot of high temperature to
accomplish because let's take the
lightest atom of them all which is what
I don't know maybe hydrogen hydrogen you
got it so hydrogen in its nucleus has
one proton right and helium in its
nucleus has two protons
plus two neutrons so how am I going to
create a helium atom from a hydrogen
atom
so you got to get a bunch of hydrogen
atoms together all right together
together well here's the here's what no
one is telling you in the news but it's
obvious when you think about it
what do two protons want to normally do
they're probably positive charge they
don't they they like each other but they
don't like each other because they're
alike
okay it's like when you it's like when
you meet somebody at a cocktail party
and they remind you of yourself and
you're just like I don't like that dude
I don't really like that I won't be over
there talking to that dude
Tucker's still in therapy people I know
exactly
like it's a simple question Chuck where
did cocktail parties and liking people
come in yeah but they they want to get
away from each other right so these are
like charges they're so in the case of
two protons they repel
so right how do you get them to come
together as a new helium nucleus if they
want to repel
so this is like rolling a ball up a hill
all right if you don't give it enough
energy it's not going to reach the top
it's not going to reach the top okay
there you go so yeah if you roll it
faster and faster giving it more and
more energy eventually the ball will
reach the top and tip and go over and
fall on the other side of the Hill
that is precisely what's going on with
two protons here it goes the two
problems want to come near each other
but they repel let's boost the
temperature which speeds everything up
they get closer to each other
before they repel
boosts the temperature some more they
get even even closer there's a magic
temperature at which these protons will
come close enough so that an entire new
Force operates
it would have to be a strong force in
the nucleus to keep two protons together
in fact the name of that Quantum love he
he
that's called Quantum love oh okay
where's that disco so I remember Jungle
Love remember Jungle Love
uh yeah Quantum love is like
Consciousness until you cross over the
barrier and then you're there
so when they cross that barrier a strong
force that operates in the nucleus takes
over it's one of the fundamental forces
of nature and it's called
the strong nuclear force
there it is okay that's what it's called
it is a very short-range Force
it only operates on scales as small as
the nucleus itself
wow but you have to get there for it to
grab a hold of you and make a new atom
that's why it takes high density
pressure and high temperature to
overcome that all right so that is
um
that is Thermo nuclear fusion Thermo is
hot nuclear is the nucleus right Fusion
they're bringing it together it turns
out that when you do that
your products have less mass than when
you started with
whoa my gosh where did the man yeah go
exactly E equals m c squared you might
look my lovely so the mass on the one
side of the equation if you lose it it
manifests on the other side of the
equation as energy
there you go there it is and so they
match Fusion so at the Lawrence
Livermore Laboratories using lasers
and by the way they've led the world in
lasers like for decades in fact people
on the inside call it lasers lasers and
lasers okay Lawrence Livermore National
Lab okay
lasers lasers and lasers lasers right
right so
so anyhow so they have managed to you
can add up how much energy it takes to
turn on the lasers and fire them and
then look at how much energy comes out
after you've done this
and they got 50 percent more energy out
of this than the energy of the lasers
that went into it
that's amazing amazing first time that's
ever happened now that now that's it now
that's an energy source now because you
got more out than you got in which is
what I want to know which is so what
what did it take what would it what
would it be what did it measure like is
it anything significant percentage-wise
that's great but like what would it take
to turn this into it if it just broke
even that would be a mess unto itself
right but the fact that they got 50 more
energy out than they put in it's it says
oh my gosh we can get the physics
to succeed
and for my money I'm saying if the
physics works then it's just a matter of
time before Engineers I got this I got
that I'm gonna make something out of
that I got that and so that's amazing
yeah and so I'm very much look forward
there's a civilization pivoting on this
result and by the way what I just
described to you the sun does every
moment of its life
the problem over all these years is of
course we've known how to make fusion
we've got we didn't know how to make
fusion since about 1949 or something but
the first Fusion bombs are called
hydrogen bombs
they're using hydrogen that's what I
just told you we two protons is merging
hydrogen atoms nuclei together so we've
known how to make fusion forever
right the challenge is not how do you
make fusion how do you control it
yeah because you don't want the electric
company
um having to move to a new city because
there's no City left right exactly
foreign
so while in America America we're really
good at blowing stuff up we're less good
at controlling that explosion right so
the Holy Grail was can we undergo fusion
in a controlled way where one day you
might be able to throttle it or contain
it or transport it and we'll finally get
maybe that ending scene in Back to the
Future
right here's your cue doc Marty it's
your kids
[Laughter]
and do you remember how uh you know and
and and Marty says but doc we're gonna
get the energy there's no lightning bolt
and there's no room for you know how
what are you gonna do and remember what
he does
he dumps a bunch of trash into uh the
flux capacitor which is now powered by
Fusion it's Mr home Fusion right it was
like a like a blender that's right it
puts it in and that undergoes nuclear
fusion and so one day perhaps we'd have
Fusion reactors in every car
and then you could like wow there it is
so so this one that transformed
civilization
even yeah regardless of the carbon
footprint that it doesn't have it would
transform civilization but it also
happens to not have a carbon footprint
so we could Stave off
this growth of fossil fuel Burning uh
and greenhouse gases and we'll still
have to recover from the damage we've
already done because a lot of the carbon
dioxide got up took into the oceans and
if you start removing it from the
atmosphere it begins to come out of the
oceans and it'll do that until it
becomes equal again so you gotta like
recover that
but right it is the future and just I
might tip my hat to this physicists and
engineers at the National Labs and this
whole thing was important enough it was
a press conference announced by the
Secretary of Energy
so oh yeah yeah we're chomping at the
beginning so then it is good news good
news I suspected accurately yes
all right had we been at it for decades
just thought I'd tell you that
and so this will be a benchmark day uh
the first week in first and second week
of December in the year 2022. we'll look
back on that another day in December
that will live not in infamy what is it
when it's a good thing for me just feel
me
okay
all right Chuck we gotta end it there
all right all right but it's way more
about like Fusion that's another show
we'll talk about stars yeah it's more
and why stars explode all right I I'll
leave a teaser here you ready fusion you
get energy by combining little atoms
Vision you get energy by splitting big
atoms
okay but wait a minute
there's got to be some point in the
Middle where these two phenomenon meet
what happens then
therein is the or the the seeds of the
undoing of great massive stars in the
universe that's a whole other explainer
we'll get to oh yeah nuclear fusion in a
nutshell this has been at yet another
Stark talk explainer great to have you
join us uh putting Fusion back on the
map Chuck always good to have you
always pleasure Neil deGrasse Tyson here
keep looking up
[Music]